we are about to head in to the basement
of the national museum of clay here in
Rochester New York they've recently made
one acquisition of games that is so
mind-blowing so amazing and so
incredibly rare I had to come here and
check it out for myself
so come all this way what is it exactly
that you guys have acquired here at the
Museum
so we've required this absolutely
phenomenal collection of close to 7,000
Japanese in European video games this is
going to be the largest public
collection of Japanese video games in
the world all right let's do it all
right well I'll show you the good stuff
let's say so you've got here's the
here's the expansion pack to dosha in
the giant and this is really really hard
to find sixty-four TV games this is this
is incredibly hard to find that mega
drive version of Tetris this is amazing
I can't believe I'm holding out of this
because there's there's like ten of
these I don't think they were supposed
to make this I think they made a couple
of them and then they somehow leaked out
I don't believe it was sold in stores
that's that's that's incredible yeah and
just to pull out of random box no look
it's one of the rarest video games in
the world they're one of the best video
games of all time ever made anywhere say
condensed in situ which is known in the
US as Secret of Mana you've got to be
kidding me I'm all I'm seeing is the
spines of these games that are sitting
here
these were promotional games yep but
also on contest prices a little bit so
the Nintendo version yep well I mean
obviously mother alright and so I mean
if you played recently just recently
re-released on the Virtual Console for
the Wii U you can play earthbound which
is actually mother - you've got Bionic
Commando which was actually known as top
secret return of Hitler in Japan
I swear that that is the name that is
printed on this box this was more than
Sapir for the NES like in Japan it was
has been done yeah yeah they had to
change that for America yeah yeah I just
took it look too real yeah so the laser
active this was the the richest of the
rich kids toy I mean back in the 90s
because like you had I mean it cost an
absurd amount of money to buy a laser
active these are the cd-rom games this
guy's collection of PC
and stuff he collected them and they're
all still see they are all still sealed
and it's all of them yes you know but
yeah I have a mild heart attack oh not a
big heart attack but it's one of the
smaller I'm touching right now the
rarest game gear box in ever in the
world and it's always the game you would
at least suspect that is the the rarest
most you know and again Bart vs. the
world was you know that was that was on
the list as well as far as like you know
just just super hard boxes to track down
Shannon thank you so much I really
appreciate getting to go back there and
paw through all those boxes of video
game
hey guys what video game do you think
belongs in a museum let us know in the
comments and then subscribe Wired's
youtube channel for more game life
videos